Morzine gegen Michael Kretzschmar
radikale Gegner der Corona Maßnahmen
sollen in einer Chat Gruppe geplant
haben den sächsischen
Ministerpräsidenten zu töten
damit der Sonderkommission
Rechtsextremismus der socorex der
sächsischen Landespolizei 6 Objekte hier
in Dresden und im benachbarten Heidenau
eine Arbeitsstätte und fünf Wohnungen
wir sind hier in Dresden Pieschen in der
rehefelder Straße das eines dieser
Objekte und inzwischen hat das LKA
mitgeteilt die Polizei dass der
Anfangsverdacht bestätigt wurde das
bedeutet dass man also auch Waffen
gefunden haben soll bestätigt ist das
konkret noch nicht es ist wie gesagt nur
vom Anfangsverdacht er bestätigt wurde
die Rede verhaftet wurde auch noch
niemand zumindest ist diese Information
das letzte was wir von den Beamten hier
erfahren haben im Moment werden die
Wohnungen durchsucht es werden von
Beamten hier vor Ort diverse Kisten
diverse Unterlagen immer wieder runter
getragen aus durch ein Wohnhaus Michael
vielen Dank für diese ersten Information